(light mystical music)
- [Voiceover] Tampo.
- [Voiceover] When you're
not really angry at someone,
but you're not really
happy about them either.
- [Voiceover] Pambahay.
- [Voiceover] A comfortable set of clothes
usually worn at home,
away from judging eyes.
- [Voiceover] Lambing.
- [Voiceover] An intense tenderness,
sweetness, and affection
rolled into one word.
- [Voiceover] Papak.
- [Voiceover] To eat a
food item that's usually
eaten with rice on it's own.
- [Voiceover] Gigil.
- [Voiceover] An intense urge to pinch
something or someone really cute.
It could also be an expression of anger,
so use with discretion.
- [Voiceover] Pikon.
- [Voiceover] Refers to people who are
hot-headed, easily
angered, or sore losers.
- [Voiceover] Umay.
- [Voiceover] The feeling
of being satiated after
eating a particular food
over and over again.
- [Voiceover] Kilig.
- [Voiceover] The feeling
of being on cloud nine,
usually associated with romantic feelings.
- [Voiceover] Torpe.
- [Voiceover] A person who is too shy
to express or pursue amorous desires.
- [Voiceover] Lihi.
- [Voiceover] An irrational
craving for something,
often associated with pregnant women.
(upbeat translucent music)